-Guys, finally, it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome!
Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
we should post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you
five different tweets.
We're all gonna vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
Yep.
You can vote for all of them,
you can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want, and we're
gonna see the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
do you have your clickers, too?
-Got it, got it.
-All right, you got it?
All right, now, whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out live
on the show
so that you can all like it
and "wetweet" it.
-Oh.
-It's a shared experience.
You guys ready?
-Yes!
-All right.
The first tweet is...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
"Playing --
Playing with blocks we are."
Yeah, no one can
talk like that forever.
They grow out it.
All right, here we go.
The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
[ Drum roll ]
Ooh, not bad!
114!
That's good, that's positive.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a good start.
It's a good start.
I like this next one, I think.
-This one you like the best?
-This one, I think, so far.
This next one I like better --
-Better than the Yoda one.
-I think so.
[ Laughter ]
-Think you do.
-Either way, I'm voting now.
I didn't even say it.
-Oh, really?
You didn't even read it.
You're just gonna vote.
-I'm gonna read it,
but this one's pretty good.
This next one is...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-I agree.
Yeah.
-Yeah?
-Yeah.
-I think --
-Factual.
That is a factual statement.
-Yeah, the audience doesn't seem
to like it at all.
-Not humorous.
[ Laughter ]
-I think this one --
-I didn't say it was humorous.
I said it was factual.
-I think Yoda is going to win
over this one.
Let's see the results.
-Oh!
-All right, a little bit more.
All right.
Appreciate that.
Thank you. A little bit more.
-A little barn burner there.
-All right, let's go
to the next one here.
It says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-"You don't know
how good you got it."
-"You don't understand
how hard we had it."
-Yeah.
-We had to take one out
and put -- make sure
the other one was rewound.
A lot of problems, yeah.
All right.
Let's see the results here.
I think it's higher than 122.
Let's see.
Oh, yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
All right, here we go.
Next up is...
[ Laughter ]
That's great.
Yeah, I love it.
-There's the door.
-"Get out."
Yeah, yeah.
That's getting a vote.
That's gonna -- that's so good.
"Live, laugh, leave.
Get out."
Let's see the results
on this one.
Oh!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Clicks tongue ]
Bang!
That one's gonna be hard to top.
-177.
-I think that's the winner.
But we do have one more.
-Is it any good?
-Yeah, this one's good.
This last one is...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
"I just -- I can't get away
from these people!"
[ Laughter ]
All right.
Let's see what
the audience voted for.
-Oh!
So the winner is...
The winner is number four.
So the winner is,
"'Live, Laugh, Leave'
would be a much better
kitchen sign."
I'm gonna post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "wetweet,"
and enjoy.